as you've noticed we aren't actually
testing that new function yet
fortunately we have a pretty good spot
in doing background to do that after all
right here we've already parsed
everything we need to call that function
so we can just call long location ID
equals add location city name location
query city.latitude + city.longitude it
would be useful for our contract to have
another method one that converts a date
object to the form at our database uses
note that Android studio may have
trouble importing the state object since
Java has two day classes one in
databases and one in Java dot util we
want Java dot util dot date back in the
fetchweathertask we're going to collect
the data from JSON into the weather
array all right so we now have a whole
bunch of data that needs to be inserted
guess we're going to do next